[Music]
the russian invasion was launched with
terrifying speed and against a wide
range of targets right across the
country
the long military buildup around
ukraine's borders finally unleashed by
order of the kremlin
helicopter gunships fighter jets
missiles tanks convoys of armored
vehicles are all involved in what russia
calls a military operation
for the moment the targets appear to be
specific and strategic they include
ukraine's airfields and military bases
this video from molitopol in southern
ukraine appears to show the destruction
of the city's airfield
the shrapnel and shells are also
reported to have landed in civilian
areas
including the capital kiev
until the very last moment i didn't
believe it would happen i thought it
might just involve donetsk and luhansk
but i didn't ever think it would involve
kiev
most likely war has now begun everyone
is leaving everywhere is shut
i hate the country that started this war
i speak as a mother and as a ukrainian
and i call on the whole world to help us
and stop this aggressor
ukraine's government declared martial
law
[Music]
i had a conversation with us president
joe biden the u.s is starting to gather
international support
today we need you each of you to be calm
if possible stay at home please we are
working the army is working the entire
security and defense sector of ukraine
is working
the russian military offensive follows a
carefully choreographed strategy of
russia's president vladimir putin
he unilaterally recognized two
separatist regions in eastern ukraine as
independent of kiev and then sent
russian soldiers in under the pretext of
being peacekeepers
the battle for luhansk and donetsk in
eastern ukraine has been going on since
2014
with more than 14 000 people killed in
fighting between the russian-backed
separatists and the ukrainian army
now what putin calls peacekeepers are on
the attack and the russian leader is
warning ukrainian soldiers not to resist
when you put themselves whoever would
try to stop us and further create
threats to our country to our people
should know that russia's response will
be immediate and lead you to such
consequences that you have never faced
in your history we are ready for any
outcome
the russian invasion began despite
last-ditch appeals from members of the
united nations security council to ease
tension
ukraine's ambassador to the un demanded
his russian counterpart stepped down as
chairman call putin called lavrov
to stop aggression
there is no purgatory for war criminals
they go straight to hell ambassador
as news of the invasion spread in
ukraine's capital kiev main highways out
of the city quickly became gridlocked
with traffic
there's a mood of desperation developing
now many people just jumping into their
cars getting their families together and
heading on the road trying to get to
poland
but the main auto routes are all jammed
there are so many people trying to do
the same thing others are going
underground taking shelter
others have been flocking to the
supermarkets and frantically stocking up
on essential items
this was the scene in kramatorsk in the
east of ukraine as shoppers grab what
they could to fill their cupboards
the ukrainian army and air force are
putting up a fight and resisting the
russian attack
this video from the defense ministry
said to show a russian helicopter shot
down by ukrainian forces near kiev
but there will be no reinforcements from
nato
and the odds look heavily stacked
against ukraine's forces
andrew simmons al jazeera kiev